sono veramente contento di poter fare
secondo episodio di un gioco che per me
merita
qualsiasi cosa nella vita prove siamo
ritornati ragazzi su art de golf eravamo
rimasti che aveva trovato la parte dello
spazio e non vedo l'ora di riscoprire
che cos'altro ci riserva questo gioco
incredibile se non lo sapete è un gioco
di golf però non è proprio un
normalissimo cento poi le buche ma sono
tutte strade e questa cosa mi fa
impazzire quindi siamo al secondo
episodio
vediamo cosa succede allora qua credo
che ci sia la gravità aumenta c'è
proprio un razzo sotto la pallina va
bene ma devo atterrare occhio aspetto
assetto aspetta senza fretta ancora
pinato bravissimo ico va a vedere giorno
fatta e niente l'obiettivo quindi
ragazzi arrivare a sbloccare tutte le
aree quindi siamo nell'area dello spazio
due su cinque ne devo fare per la riva
propria asta porta 2 su 5 vuol dire che
ne mancano alcuni tipo questo
l'obiettivo non è colpire non e centra
la buca ma è centrale la bandierina non
è così facile come sembra invece value
molto molto lontano
madonna al bordello qua questa è la vedo
difficile che i gol stellare
va bene ci sta un t ciao tizio su un
gatto qui poi sto rischiando e ragga pro
ci provo dai torna giù dove la padova
impegnati bravo bravo questa è giusta
questa giusta no aspetta che un casino
mi sono attaccato pianeta aiuto e non
riesco a scendere le scale scendere nel
salire rimango qua porca vacca morda
niente ragazzi difficilissimo sono
riuscito a morire a bari mi ha fregato o
huston buca in uno dove la pallina a io
con questa pallina come possibile un
pianeta era la palla vai esiste gioco
tutto strano manca solo questo
un tiro e bastava la baie roba ma che
sveglia gli fino adesso
[Musica]
ma come questo bravo devo dire che è
successo un casino
ce l'ho fatta eccolo vamos dentro dentro
una di dentro qui adesso che abbiamo
totalmente tipo di livello
andiamo qua a destra tipo ii nostro e
vedo che c'è una macchina scontata
proviamoci
o siamo ritornati sui livelli normali
normali si fa per dire vediamo cosa esce
fuori le coop
adesso hanno aggiunto l'esplosivo devi
togliere questo lo rivela abbastanza
normale per quanto riguarda otto gioco
però teoricamente hanno aggiunto gli
ostacoli anche per raggiungere in belice
ma sono parole ma veramente quindi
questi sono livelli normali però
intervallati da problematiche ma buono
capito è la vedo difficile come passo di
qua salva dolenti invece non esclude
niente nou esplode tutto comunque basali
mezzo zio bravissimo tutto in area salta
devo arrivare alle altre no no no
è un gioco difficile ragazzi tocca la
macchinina piano no vabbè vabbè ho detto
piano il casinò non sono arrivare la
teoricamente ci dovrei fare se gioco di
sponda non ce l'ha fatta
l'ex co big bada grande va da quando
aggiunto l'esplosivo comunque ragazzi
che è veramente difficile ha raggiunto
anche le macchine tostapane quello no è
scarso che gioco veramente è l'apoteosi
che buca no madonna sembra vip casa la
vera incredibile endrigo
non esclusa niente tranquillo andiamo
avanti
mancano ancora due buche per riuscire a
sbloccare quel pezzo quindi questo qua
madonna raga le macchine sono in vari
una radio di troppa roba troppo
difficile con le macchine se partono em
up e allora o giovedì scolo di tutto
l'importante che nessuno ne abbia
toccato va bene questo oggi sono di
nuovo io non so se lancerò la pallina
dai volto semi lancio io stesso però
proviamo bilancio io la mazza in teoria
dovrebbe arrivare
ho segnato con la mazza ha fatto gol
fantastico non ho scritto da luca devo
arrivare ovviamente ragazzi non siete i
soli episodi sono guardatelo vi prego
l'obiettivo arrivare con la pallina alla
bocca ma la pallina non è sempre la
pallina anche gli ogni tanto sa papali
quindi l'importante è arrivare le preso
l'ultimo maledetta macchina ok ci sono
rimasti perfetto vai
l'ultimo suo augurio bello c'è una
discesa mega cosa faccio più gli
esplosivi che cadono infinocchiato di
brutta aria a posto oggi occhio di nuovo
libro non c'è un'agenda debutto mamma
mia andata benissimo
va bene allora andiamo avanti perfetto
io di qua sotto la buca non so bene
no ragazzi ma sto vedendo quello che sto
vedendo sta comandando il barile
ma veramente 9 bellissimo livelli quota
flux 9 fatemelo rifare no non lo voglio
rifare chimiche l'altro e così i temi
che l'altro i moduli bellissimo ti
permette di controllare il barile
fantastica starò la lazio c'è una miccia
aiuto a devo correre prima che la vita
mi raggiunga con devo non devo farmi il
far esplodere 0 perde occorre prima che
la cia vi raggiungo un casino madonna
quello di prima sembra qualcosa di
supermario sembra terrazzo di soffermare
uguale ok devi correre occhi non toccare
nulla hobbit livello difficile già fatta
praticamente avere sbloccato tutto
bellissimo 2 su 4 io sto casi per il
boss dorica mentre facciamo ancora uno
rai che dite diciamo questo
come vediamo nella prossima volta faccio
ancora uno e poi il boss vavalà ultimi
livelli l'aia
c'è il tipo che fa il tifo per me
l'altra padova segnare quando mandare in
buca scusami
l'obiettivo di tutti è raggiungere la
bocca ne frego però qua facciamo volta
fare gol col vento ho fatto con il
progetto big fun sarebbe grande
ventilatore vale quale dobbiamo fare il
gol con il dentro se lo metti lando
diritto ci scherzavo no ragazzi questo è
difficilissimo benissimo wow bene c'è un
portiere
gliela tiro addosso perché se come si
butta attendiamola l'angolino comunque
ragazzi là dietro sta succedendo
qualcosa di brutto e io ve lo dico qua
vedo che ci sono cose ha detto prendiamo
la traversa prendiamo la traversa evvai
però o rock in gol bellissimo questo io
[Applauso]
ok
puoi tirare i palloni da calcio in ogni
momento
in che senso ha che fare la caccia di
possono spalmare ok grazie tutto 10
quello che mi sta marcando a tifare la
caccia di quei diari conti invece a
palline da golf e non devi aspettare che
finisca il tiro va bene football
americano aiuto da comunque ragazzi
questo il miglior gioco che si trova
solo su epic games migliore in assoluto
66 perfetto lascio anche il codice
supporto creator di fianco se volete
prenderlo usato il mio codice supporto
diretto ragazzi si sono trovate è il
gioco migliore del mondo non ce n'è
allora andiamo avanti porca vacca
ronaldo chiellini aiuto se i tripla
tutti bellissimo siliquini zona 0 devo
farli fuori tutti qua ma teoricamente ci
dovrei riuscire non dovrebbe essere
difficile ma molto bene molto bene c'è
una macchina adesso la vasta la macchina
occhio si tripla tutti bellissimo triplo
lei
mancano 2 2 bandiere o finito è
praticamente non sono più due livelli e
ce l'abbiamo fatta
questo la vedo diversi così qua che
girano sono la cosa che mi fanno più
sono ancora vivo si può passare anche da
sotto volendo perché quando cadi non sei
totalmente caduto poi ancora farcela non
sono studiata perfettamente occhio qua
ci sono dei figli cos'è sta roba per
terra occhio il portiere bellissimo ce
l'abbiamo fatta ultimo
ma doppio passo grandissimo e ritorno in
campo bellissimo sono ormai è solo nei
dribbling con la pallina della bravo
bravo soccer il calcio ne dovrei avere
finito ragazzi manca solo questo e dopo
di quello teoricamente ci dovrebbe
essere
credo una sorta di boss si sblocca
questa porta qui vediamo cosa succede
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale e schiacciate il
tasto mi piace perché questo gioco lo
merita questo gioco veramente il
migliore che esista per me attualmente
nome d'ora di fare sempre questo mi
porterà altri episodi c'è anche la roba
online dunque blu detto già anche
l'altra volta però prima voglio finire
la campagna poi loro be online
ma la voglio fare piacere la
campanellina che se rimanete aggiornati
sui nuovi video che escono in scia al
prossimo vita belle ragazze
[Musica]